One paper, please.
"Hot prince visit makes
temperatures rise in the city."
Seriously, though,
what's with his hair?
I just got a call to do
the hair and makeup
for the royal wedding...
...for $50,000.
-It's like a glass slipper.
-But money.
There's the castle!
Welcome to Lavania.
-May I introduce Prince Thomas.
-I'm Izzy of 183rd Street.
You're young and in love.
-Come on, you two.
-I hardly know Lauren.
-This is nothing but
an arranged marriage.
-What are you doing here?
-I was hoping I could join you.
-Thomas.
-Hm?
You could be my Sherpa guide
to normal life.
A town car's trailing us.
-One, two, three, stop!
-What happens if we run?
-Let's find out.
Go, go!
-So why are you just a hairdresser?
-"Just"?
Truth is, I'd love nothing more
than to do something else.
-Scissors ready!
-One, two, three.
Yes, two, three.
We're in hair camp
and you're out flirting with hot royalty.
I'm not flirting with Prince Thomas.
You gave me the look.
-What look?
-This look.
Are you ready to have
your mind blown?
-Woo!
-Find Thomas and
bring him immediately.
Please. I don't want you to go.